but first donald trump won the second
most votes of any u.s
presidential candidate in history this
week but unfortunately for him
his rival joe biden won the most and the
former vice president
will move into the white house in
january but what will abide in
presidency mean
for the united kingdom well a man with a
few thoughts about that is the former
chancellor sanju javid who joins us now
thank you
very much for being with us mr javid so
did the best man win
win um i think so yes i did think that
it's the right outcome not just for the
us that's the decision of course for the
u.s people but it's the best outcome for
the uk as well i'm pleased it was a
clear result a clear sweep of the
electoral college
a a win of the popular vote as well i
also think you know
no matter what your politics it will be
just good
for us all to have some civility
uh some integrity and seriousness back
in the white house
when you're obviously a conservative but
does that mean you would have voted for
joe biden
look i don't have a vote in this it's
it's rightly a decision
uh for the american people but we are
right to think about how
this decision the the the leader of the
most powerful country in the world how
does it impact
us and i think it's good news and i
think it's good news for us for
a number of reasons because of course
joe biden will rightly govern in
u.s interest just as we govern in our
own interests but i think there's a lot
of crossover a lot of mutual
interest far more than there ever was
with a trump administration
so if you look at three or four the
biggest issues right now the pandemic
for example he will certainly be taking
it more seriously
as we do he's already said he's going to
rejoin the world health organization
we'll be chairing the g7 uh next year
for example
that means we can work on a global
recovery plan with
a man in the white house that is a
multilateralist understands the need
for international your combined action
when it comes to trade
joe biden believes in free trade donald
trump was a protectionist
and then also for example when it comes
to climate change you know we'll be
hosting
the world's largest a seriously
important climate change conference next
year
we'll be chairing that and right now we
will with the new leader of the white
house we will have someone who will want
to work with us
to bring about change um interesting to
get your take
on that now of course donald trump
refused to accept the result of
uh the election uh he's called some
votes illegal
uh he even said the accounting should be
stopped
how concerned are you about the response
to the election from donald trump
look i i think in in saying those things
he's
he's already done a huge amount of
damage to democracy both at home and his
own country and
and frankly abroad the u.s is a beacon
of democracy across the world as we are
and it is doing damages still is still
doing damage because
he hasn't stopped and yeah can we today
think of today we
in a couple of hours from now our whole
nation
uh will have a moment of silence uh to
remember those that who fought for
you know our freedoms your our democracy
and it's a reminder of just how fragile
democracy
is you know we are privileged to have
democracy the americans are privileged
to have it there are so many people
around the world that yearn for
democracy and
and you know the behavior of the u.s
president is frankly being adolescent
behavior and and i hope that serious
people around him
you'll take him aside and tell him to
stop and put an end to this
you're talking about the fragility of
democracy and the damage that donald
trump is doing to
democracy by his reaction to the
election result
but on friday downing street repeatedly
refused to say that every vote
in the u.s election should be counted i
mean it doesn't sound like that's a
controversial statement
how can we stand up for the importance
of democracy
when we can't even say that every vote
should be counted in a democratic
election
well look first writer i'm proud of what
the uk does to stand up for democracy
across the world especially the work
that we do with many
developing nations through our aid
program and stuff to strengthen their
democracy and
and governance and and to your question
i i think it's actually quite right that
a
a serving a uk minister doesn't really
comment
at all on the internal workings of
another country's
uh the elections especially as they are
ongoing and there's no result you know
if i
i'm not standing in front of you today
as a minister uh but if i were
you know i wouldn't have the flexibility
and the freedoms to say uh what i am and
your ministers
will naturally be more careful in what
they say that's quite right at the same
time
they're not they're not being asked to
comment on the election they're not
being asked to comment on what they
think of the result or anything like
that
or who they think should win it seems to
be a very
uncontroversial statement that every
vote should be counted doesn't it
of course that's a that's something i
think anyone who believes in democracy
uh would would welcome that in any
election you count every vote and
what we've seen here though in the in
the us case it's a it's the sitting
president actually encouraging
people not to count the vote but you
know as i say i think that
you know the vast majority of people
that when they hear those comments from
president trump
uh would not agree with him and i know
that certainly would be the case in the
uk government but uh
you wouldn't expect the uk government to
to give some kind of running commentary
on the u.s election
now when you were home secretary under
theresa may you
weren't invited to a state banquet with
donald trump even though other
more junior ministers were you described
the decision at the time as a bit odd
do you think that we haven't done enough
to stand up
to our value for our values with donald
trump in the past
yeah i think you know clearly we don't
choose who the u.s president is once the
american people have made that decision
we're going to of course
work with that u.s president and and
also
let's be straight that you know whilst
i'm pleased with this election result
you know donald trump does have some
achievements to his name things that
we've
worked with him only in his own uh
country his economy
is stronger he created more jobs uh
internationally he's sought to
create more peaceful relationships
between israel and its arab neighbors so
you know we will work with the us when
it suits us i think what
what what makes sense uh now is that
there's so much more mutual interest and
the kind of things i've mentioned on
trade on climate change
uh on recovery in the global economy the
the pandemic
and so all of that means i think we can
just work much more
uh closely together and this is coming
at a time when we are taking
chairmanship of many of these
multilateral organizations
and you need an international partner
you need someone who's a multilateralist
like joe biden is
that respects international rules and
and as we sort of um
leave the eu and we have an exciting
future ahead of us we need to
work with partners across the world that
also respect international rules because
we'll be relying on those now more than
ever the wto rules
uh for example and having someone in the
white house that has that respect for
uh international rules is going to be
really important at the same time though
some would be wondering if it's actually
true
that we will have a better relationship
with joe biden on things like trade i
mean donald trump of course
has said that the uk would have been at
the front of the queue for any
post-brexit trade deal he's talked about
the importance of a special relationship
we know of course he believed in brexit
unlike joe biden who said he would have
voted remain
are you not worried that actually a
trade deal with joe biden in the white
house is going to be harder to achieve
no not at all in fact i think a trade
deal with joe biden is far
more likely and let's look at the
evidence let's look at what donald trump
actually did when he was in office when
it came to trade with the uk
he slapped tariffs on uk aluminium uk
steel
your scotch whiskey and that not only
hurt people in america in terms of
higher prices
but it also costs jobs here in the uk
you know president trump is a
protectionist he's been very clear about
that he's paralyzed wto
you know we now want to strike more
trade deals across the world and
actually what you need is a president
that believes in free trade and that's
what we're going to have with joe biden
at the same time though some would also
worry about the relationship that boris
johnson
and jay biden are going to have
particularly in light of previous
comments that boris johnson has made
referring to barack obama as park kenyon
saying that hillary clinton looks like a
sadistic
mental health nurse i mean he's going to
have some ground to wake up with
joe biden isn't he after insulting some
of his friends and colleagues
i think people are wrong to be concerned
about that because you know first of all
the the uk u.s relationship is
indispensable
there have been over the last few
decades let's think there's been many
presidents and prime ministers
and whoever that personality those
personalities have been
that relationship has remained strong
because it's far bigger than
personalities
the second thing i'd say actually is i i
personally believe that the
the whole sort of thing about uh boris
johnson and
and and uh donald trump being close is
completely
overstated you know they had a good
strong
working relationship based on your
practical
uh cooperation and uh i have no doubt
that
when boris johnson and joe biden speak
they're hitting off straight away and
they'll build up a rapport because
not if nothing else they've got so many
mutual interests
now i'm keen to talk a little bit to you
about lockdown and the economy as well
obviously as a former chancellor the
government's just announced that they're
going to be extending the furlough
scheme
into march the bank of england's been
printing more money
we know of course that job cuts will be
coming
how concerned are you about the state of
the economy and what do you think
unemployment could look like
when you the uk government and
understandably along with many other
governments across the world when we
decided to have a
a lockdown especially that original uh
lockdown
that clearly when you stop consumers
from consuming producers from producing
you're going to have an economic crisis
and
in that moment what you need to do is
set out policies that will
support the economy for a quick recovery
when you can start lifting these
restrictions
so first of all i think that is exactly
what rishi sunak and the treasury team
have done i'd commend them for it i
think they've done given the
circumstances they've done an excellent
job they keep trying to sort of improve
interventions we've seen that
in the last few weeks and and like
anyone of course i'm hugely concerned
about the economic damage that the
pandemic has done across
the world and uh it's really really
important that
as we recover as we get to the other
side of the pandemic that we don't
withdraw
the support that's been provided to the
economy quickly we take our time
and uh and we manage finances in in a
way that we continue to provide
support uh to the sectors that are going
to need it most
at the same time though you know uk debt
is now bigger than gdp
and we don't know how long this is going
to go on for
there's going to be some really
difficult decisions coming up on how to
help the economy how to balance the
books what to do i mean you've described
yourself
as a low tax kind of guy but tax is
going to have to go up aren't they
so as as the chancellor has said we're
going to have to eventually
you know confront uh the public finances
and bring them back
uh under control now is not the time but
eventually we'll have to do that
and i think that the best way to do that
by the way is to you
is to control public spending even more
tightly the chancellor was right
i think recently to to postpone the full
spending review
and to to do that uh sometime next year
when we can
i think take our time and look at
spending in every government department
and do what i call
a a zero-based spending review and i
know
you know i've had five government
departments and i can tell you in every
government department
there are substantial savings and
efficiencies that can be made now
you mentioned taxes and i'm not going to
pretend with you for a second
that you're going to be able to avoid
having to raise some taxes yeah it's
clearly we're going to have to pay
uh for uh not just the the some of that
debt but we're going to have to pay for
extra spending in areas like health and
social care and
that will mean some taxes somewhere will
have to go up now is not the time
to do that and when taxes are changed i
think it's really
important that it is not taxes that that
hit work incentives or hit businesses
okay such a jabber really interesting to
talk thank you very much for being on
the program today